une douzaine de très jeunes enfants et
de parents une piscine bien chauffé
apprivoiser l'eau peut s'apprendre un
très jeune âge pour le plaisir bien sûr
mais aussi pour une question de sécurité
[Musique]
et c'est aussi pour une question de
sécurité qu'est parents achètent des
vêtements de flottaison individuel dvf y
à leurs enfants
mais ce qu'ils sont vraiment efficaces
chaque année les profs de l'école de
natation d'eau invite les parents à
porter le vfi de leurs jeunes ce qu'est
ce qu'on a dit c'est aux parents bompas
allant bateau vous avez des vestes de
sécurité a mené les on va les tester
c'est un test tout simple semblable à
celui que transports canada exige pour
approuver les gilets de sauvetage des
navets et des embarcations de plaisance
mais pas les vérifie on dépose l'enfant
plat ventre sur l'eau et en 5 secondes
ou moins la vaysse doit le renverser
qu'il soit conscient ou pas pour voir si
ça va leur tournée sur le dos faut
vraiment faire tomber l'enfant sur le
rang pour voir si la veste valeur
tournée comme s'ils tombent et aide au
bord d'une piscine comme s'ils tombaient
dans un bateau
en général ça fonctionne bien mais pas
toujours à chaque journée quand on fait
des tests on peut avoir quatre cinq
gestes qu'ils retournent paul les
enfants sur le dos d'autres qui font
fonctionner donc ça arrive quand même ce
soit lors de notre visite cet enfant de
14 à 24 mois ont passé ce test qui n'est
pas toujours facile tout leur vf y
étaient approuvés et répondaient aux
normes du fédéral la majorité ont
retourné les enfants un deux ou trois
secondes pour d'autres c'est moins
réussi
c'est le petit luca 15 mois un habitué
des cours de natation qui nous a
démontré que non les vérifie ne sont pas
infaillibles sous l'eau lucas excellent
pour retenir son souffle mais n'a pas le
réflexe de se débattre qui est immobile
comme le serait un enfant inconscient
commence à virer c'est le gong
c'est là qu'on voit qu'on va chercher
plus efficace c'est là qu'en contacter s
on se rend compte que c'est faux
peut-être investir un petit peu mieux ce
peu plus d'argent pour avoir une très
bonne santé
pourtant la vis de luca est approuvée
elle répond aux normes de transports
canada elle était adaptée à son poids et
lorsqu'on la questionne sur un autre
enfant l'a parfaitement fonctionne
c'est parce que pas un enfant qui
apparaît comme vous avez vu il ya des
enfants de 1 an qui pèse 25 lits il ya
des enfants de 3 ans qui pèse 25 les
différences de poids de physiologie de
combativité selon elle plusieurs
facteurs pourraient expliquer pourquoi
un vfi fonctionne avec un enfant et pas
un autre
les images du petit luca ont surpris le
dg de nautisme au québec mais il
rappelle qu'au pays seuls les vestes de
sauvetage doivent maintenir la tête de
l'utilisateur
hors de l'eau l'éveil fille n'ont pas
cette contrainte
la veste de flottaison individuel mais l
épaule c'est une aide à la flottabilité
elle va peut-être pour retourner dans
tous les cas comme on l'a vu par contre
les gens vont la porter davantage parce
qu'elle est plus confortable en fait
transports canada exige simplement que
le vfi maintiennent l'utilisateur face
vers le haut sans avoir tendance à lui
ramener le visage dans l'eau parce qu'il
ya un intérêt éventuellement à aborder
et des règlements plus stricts pour
l'événement de l'été entre eux pour les
enfants je suis qu'un transport canada
travaillent actuellement à définir
toutes les catégories de flottabilité
puis de pour pour tout les verts flattr
dont est ce qu'ils vont aller vers ce
que vous dites ça c'est encore un jeune
crois pas que c'est sur la table
présentement mais ce serait souhaitable
effectivement pour les plus jeunes de
peut-être améliorer les normes
la seule veste qui fait qu'on se
retourne sur le dos et une veste de
sauvetage
après plus de 30 ans d'enseignement et
dit tremblay n'a qu'un conseil à donner
aux parents d'enfants très jeunes
d'affaires le plus important c'est qu'un
parent ne devrait jamais avoir une
distance plus qu'un bras de son enfant
lors ce qui est près d'un plan d'eau ici
normand grondin du canada montréal